hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the algaer gambit
which is a night sacrifice in the king's
gambit so you're already giving up a
pawn and then you decide to give up a
knight for a very strong attack so the
king's game it starts out with e4
e5 and then f4 this is my favorite
opening in chess after the pawn takes we
played knight f3
stopping the queen coming down to h4
and then this variation black plays pawn
to g5
preparing to push forward and attack the
knight on f3 we play h4 and they play a
g4 and then in this game bit we're going
to be playing knight g5 now not too long
ago i did make a video on the kizioski
gambit which is knight e5
these moves while they may look similar
both of the knight moves are attacking
the square on f7 they play very
very differently so definitely recommend
if you play knight to f3
and then you see your opponents playing
pawn g5 preparing to push forward h4
pretty common i recommend looking at
both of these variations and then just
see what you feel like you prefer but in
this video where we are going to be
looking at knight to g5 and the main
reason this is so different is once our
opponent plays h6
we are forced to sacrifice our knight on
f7 you can see there's no place for our
knights to go it can't come back to h3
f3 because of the pawns can't come up
here to e6 obviously and then h7 would
die as well so we're going to be
sacrificing right away our knights on
f7 after the king takes we are then
going to get our bishop involved to c4
now that's going to be most of the
variations we are going to look at we
are also going to look at what happens
if they don't play h6 some of the common
themes you could see maybe knight to f6
or another thing i've seen is pawn to
f3
this video is brought to you by aim
chess more from them later in
the video
so the first variation we are going to
look at is the main line and that is h6
because it forces white to play
knight takes on f7
and then after the king takes we are
going to play that bishop to c4
from here black will usually just
respond with king to e8
and you can start to see that none of
black's pieces on the eighth rank have
moved they've heavily extended on the
king side with the pawns on f4 and g4 so
white has to be extremely aggressive to
attack black if black's able to hold off
the attack black's gonna be better off
white sacrificed a knight so both sides
are equal in pawns but white is down a
minor piece but in chess it's all about
the pieces involved in the attack so
even though black has more material if
white can somehow use the pieces
involved at the attack better they are
going to be better off but for sure if
black can play defensively correctly
they will have the upper hand so white's
gonna try to get more and more material
involved into the game starting with
queen two
g4 now the three variations we are going
to look at in this situation the first
one is knight f6 attacking the queen
here the next one is pawn d5
and then the last one is queen f6 so
let's look at the first one knight f6
attacking the queen on g4
this is not a great move from black
white's gonna play queen g6 attacking
the king here king comes to e7 no not a
lot of great options you can start to
see and then e5 this is attacking the
knights here
and the knight doesn't have a lot of
good moves but you can start to see all
the threats that white has they have
queen taking on
f6 that's pretty obvious but they can
also come to f6
with the check on the king and that
would also be checkmate so
black has a tough situation that they
have to worry about okay so let's look
at some of the options uh they could
start with
d5
but now we can just take that knight on
f6 maybe they play king to e8 we play
bishop c5 and then when they play c6 we
can take their rook on h8 yes they do
take our
bishop but white's in a much better
position in the game now if we come back
what if they don't play d5 what if they
play h7 okay they we just looked at the
queen takes on h8 so what if they say
yes now i'm going to protect the queen
coming to f7 with the rook and it gets
it out of harm's way if the queen ever
tries to attack the h8 square but the
other threat that we have is the queen
taking on f6 and so king to e8 then we
can play
queen g6 check
and then we're just going to capture
that rook this is not going to go well
it is going to end in a checkmate pretty
soon here now if we come back what if
the knight moves okay so we already
looked at we can attack the knight so if
it just comes to e4
well then we can just play queen uh f7
and this is checkmate okay so that's not
going to work so we recognize that
knight to f6 not really the strongest
move what if they try something else
what if they play pawn
d5
ok well now we can just play
queen h5
and they can't play king d7 although it
looks like it's getting out of harm's
way this would actually be
a huge mistake because then we could
play queen d5 this is gonna be a
checkmate pretty soon bishop to d6 tries
to hold on to it but you can see there's
no good spot for them to go if they come
to c6 it's going to be checkmate right
away if they come back let's say
king 2e8
well now we just have queen f7 this is
going to be
checkmate so king 2 d7 in this spot
is not going to work
the other option they could try is
king e7 but you see it's pretty awkward
it blocks off the queen it blocks off
the dark square bishop
and we're still going to just come over
to e5 checking the king and attacking
the rook on h8
now bishop to e6 sure but now we could
take with our pawn attacking the bishop
the bishop is pinned down from this
queen so that gets pretty tricky queen
d6 but now we can just take that rook on
h8 yeah we could exchange in the center
of the board here but then we castle and
we're threatening the pawn on f7 or
excuse me on f4 uh we're also
threatening this pawn on h6 depending on
what they do with their knight we're
threatening that they have to defend it
with their queen we can always play
knight c3 with tempo attacking the queen
and then we can start to push forward
with our d-pawn we're the only piece or
we're the only side with a central pawn
attacking now with our bishop on f4 so
we have a lot of threats should be a
pretty easy
game for
white
now if we come back we looked at what
happens if they play knight to f6 we
also look what happens if they play pawn
d5
but really the best move because both of
those are bad is for black to play queen
f6 if they haven't played this as black
it's i think it's tricky to find queen
to f6 as the best move but this is
definitely what they should play before
we go over this variation a quick word
from aimchess
one of the best ways to improve at chess
is using aimchest their software has
some features i think you're absolutely
going to love let's say you're watching
this video and you just want to do some
basic analysis to see if white's winning
or losing in a position you can come
through the king's gambit and if you're
watching this video you may say
okay but what happens after knight to g5
is white winning or losing and you can
see that if the engine's on but not only
that you can look in other videos and
see where this exact position has ever
showed up and you can do this for any
opening so you can see in this position
at 4 35 in this video this exact
situation comes up and it has it for
multiple openings let's come down here
to one i did on the muzio gambit you can
click on this and it's not just my
videos but you can see it shows that
exact position so pretty cool feature if
you're studying different openings and
you want to see where unique position
has shown up maybe for your own games
you want to see how you perform one of
the great things about aim chess is when
you first sign up you link up your
chess.com account your chess 24 lead
chess and so it can start to do some
really cool analysis on it maybe if
you're looking at openings and you want
to see how you perform in some of the
popular openings are you getting ahead
or are you falling behind because maybe
you're making some mistakes you can see
all the different openings you play and
how you actually score coming out of
those openings let's say you want to do
some practice on your own games remember
this is all customized to you you can
click on the opening improver and it
will say
hey you've made this mistake nine times
in your own games this is all unique to
you and so you can practice to make sure
you don't make the same mistake again
not only does it have opening tactics
but you can do just regular tactics or
blunders that you've done in the past
it's all dedicated to focusing on your
games and helping you improve so if you
want to check out aimchess again one of
the best ways to improve you definitely
can there's a link in the description
below also there's a code
for 30 off so i've partnered with
aimchat you can use that code to get 30
off definitely think you're gonna enjoy
it but check that out and improve right
away
now you may notice that the bishop and
the queen are both eyeing down this
knight on g8 and you can say well why is
the queen on f6 that good if black's
going to lose this material on g8 but it
would be a huge mistake if white took on
g8
because black has
the subtle move h5 they definitely don't
want to just take with their rook
because then the queen can take on g8
huge mistake but they have h5 and this
forces the queen off the g file it can't
stay anywhere here on this file because
it would die so let's say it comes back
f3 then all of a sudden black takes on a
g8 the reason this is important remember
white gave up a knight early in the game
so that they could have a strong attack
that light square bishop was a huge
attacker for white as soon as that comes
off the board white doesn't have a lot
of threats immediately involved in the
game right now the bishop is blocked off
it's going to take a couple moves for
that to get involved into the game yes
knight to c3 but that's not any more
involved than knight to c6
and because white was already down that
night early on it's going to be pretty
easy for black to win this game so
definitely don't want to take on g8
instead we're going to be looking to
play d4 this allows white to control the
center of the board get the dark square
bishop involved into the game
preparing knight to c3 at some point if
you want to but white now has both pawns
in the center
and it puts black to a test because how
do they really
defend from here
usually in the kings game but you see
something like d6 but that would be a
huge mistake because
this light square diagonal is already
controlled by the queen because you know
white can just take on c8 so they can't
play d6 right now really the only option
they're looking at is to play
knight c6
now we are going to push forward with e5
they'll probably come back to g7 one of
the better moves they can make a lot of
mistakes here as you can imagine we're
going to gobble up this material on f4
remember not trying to just trade down
material if we trade down material
that's better for black as we get to the
end game if all the pieces are off the
board they are going to be up that minor
piece so you want to keep our
heavy material involved into the game
and this is also a trap because if they
tried to capture on g2 and say hey if
you're gonna take my pawn i'm gonna take
your pawn as well then this would be
checkmate because we have queen two f7
and then king d8 and then queen takes f8
and this is going to be checkmate so
they can't take that pawn on g2
so more than likely now they could try
something like d6 okay getting the light
squared bishop involved uh we can't take
with our queen right away and even if
our queen was on the light square
because the knight moved to c6 now the
rook can defend that bishop but white
can get more pieces involved into the
game remember that is the entire game
plan for white so castle on the king's
side while our king's not that safe
that's okay all we really want to do is
have it slightly better but also get our
rook to this f-file now we have our
bishop queen and rook all eyeing down on
the f-file which is extremely good
if they decide to take that's fine
because now we can play knight c3 and
this also
allows them to make the mistake of
taking with their knight because if they
take with their knight we take with our
queen
we have a pretty good set up here we can
get our bishop to f4 we're still
threatening this f7 squares if they do
anything with their queen we still have
that threat
also we can come up and take on c7 at
some point depending on where their
queen is always have to look out for
their queen
but we just have a lot of threats once
our bishop comes to f4 we can get our
rook to the center of the board so a lot
of threats that black has to do with
white's in a pretty good spot here even
though they gave up that minor piece
earlier and they do have an extra pawn
over their
opponent
now coming back here that was all based
on if the queen comes to f6 which black
definitely should black is ahead in this
position white has to be extremely
aggressive but even at the beginning
black doesn't have to play h6 now i
think it's the main line you'll see
quite often and so you're forced to take
on f7 but if they don't play h6 you're
not forced to take on f7 so a couple
other options you could see one is
knight to f6
but then we're going to push forward e5
attacking the knight they have a few
ways they could respond if they move
their knight which i think is a poor
variation let's say knight h5
we take on a g4 with our queen attacking
their knights pretty much have to come
back to g7
we're just going to keep gobbling up
material here
so this is going to be pretty bad if
they try something else maybe
knights
e5 or d5
none of those are really good you know
e5 it loses to our knight here if they
play d5 then we just play bishop c4
which is what we want to do the entire
time
c6 to defend the knights but then we can
just play knight c6 attacking this
knight here we can always play queen g4
we're just getting more and more
material involved into the game we have
a piece that's really annoying here on
e5 we're putting a lot of pressure on
the f7 square
and from black standpoint they move this
knight all around the board and it's not
really protecting
too much
of the critical squares so if they try
to move their knight that's not going to
be good really the best option in this
case which i don't think they should be
playing knight f6 anyway but if we play
e5 they should play
queen e7 because now our pawn is pinned
that we can't take the knights on f6
we can go ahead and just play d4 opening
up for the dark square bishop to get
involved into the game solidifying the
pawn chain in the center a little bit
now black could still force us that h6
move attacking the knight we are still
going to take with our knights on f7
and so if they take with their king
that's fine if they take with their
queen we're just going to take their
knight because we're no longer pinned so
my guess is they're just going to take
with their king so we can't take their
knight right here but then we can play
bishop to f4
we'll get in this position essentially
look to castle on the queen side at some
point played knight to c3 get our queen
to uh g4 depending on where their knight
is can't play it right away but we do
have some options we can always cast on
the king side and put that rook on the
f1 file so that's going to be pretty
good as well
as we don't have to worry about the pit
anymore so white has some options here
knight to c6 we could play bishop to c4
attacking the king so really depends on
where our opponent's going their bishops
are kind of locked out here the rook on
a8 is not doing too much so wall white
did give up that night on f7 you can see
the king's in that awkward spot and
white can really attack for the rest of
the game
now that's what happens if they played
knight to f6 the last version we are
going to look at is f3
because they're not attacking the knight
we don't have to move the knight right
away we are always looking to get more
material involved into the game and the
king's gamut so bishop c4 attacking the
f7 square
and really the threat is hey if you want
to come down and attack on g2 that's
fine you take on g2 we're just gonna
come up and take on f7 check
probably going to come to e7
it's just such an awkward move for them
they can't take the bishop it's
protected by the knight and so the king
is blocking off the queen and the bishop
now we're going to play g1 don't want to
allow them to take that rook and promote
to a queen and check our king extremely
bad so that's really our only option is
to play rook g1 but then how do they
respond well really they need to play h6
but then we can play
d4 yes they can take our knights but it
would be a pretty huge mistake because
if they take with their pawn then we can
play bishop
takes on a g5
you can see
this is attacking the king and if they
move that king
then we're going to take their queen on
d8 so they can't really do that
so instead knight to f6 really the only
option here
and then we can just come back and play
bishop d5 getting out of harm's way
we can now play e5 attacking that pin
piece the knight can't move is being
attacked by the bishop so that's now
under attack we can even play queen g4
right away because remember that knight
can't move
so we have a lot of threats black is
going to be in a very very tough spot so
there are some cute ways that they could
try to
defend in this spot early on instead of
playing h6
but if they don't play h6 i think black
is in a pretty tough spot so
really what you're usually going to see
is h6 and then f7 and then after the
king takes we're going to be playing
bishop c4
thank you all so much for watching the
video remember to check out the link in
the description below to learn more
about aim chess
and improve your game if you have
suggestions for other videos you want me
to make let me know in the comments
below but i will see you guys in the
next video
you